avec nous ce soir jean charest qui est
le premier qui a été premier ministre du
québec de 2003 2012 associé du cabinet
mme eckert était trop bonsoir monsieur
charest françois fillion vous êtes
membre du groupe de travail de
l'institut canadien du wilson center à
washington qui réfléchit justement la
réouverture de la frontière
est ce que comme le dit l'iata le temps
est venu selon vous de rouvrir la
frontière ce que j'interprète de la
déclaration du président de lille c'est
le fait qu' on confond les mesures de
sécurité avec des mesures dissuasives et
aucun doute monsieur fillion que les
gouvernements ont mis en place des
restrictions qui sont des mesures qui
sont faits dans le but de dissuader les
gens de voyager et en imposant des
contraintes ça ça rend impossible d fois
très difficile de se déplacer et comme
une la situation évolue avec les vaccins
ben là on anticipe des réouvertures et
c'est vrai pour la frontière entre le
canada et les états unis on arrive à
l'étape où nous devons je crois
préparer un plan de réouverture ce n'est
pas le cas à l'heure actuelle on ne peut
pas en tout cas eu de déclaration du
gouvernement fédéral américain ou
canadien sur place ouverture mais on y
arrive et on devrait pouvoir anticiper
les ouvertures sécuritaire mais
graduelle qui permettrait aux gens de
mieux circuler entre les deux pays on
entend 21 juin c'est à dire qu'on a la
frontière est officiellement fermée avec
les états unis jusqu'au 21 juin
mais il semble circuler des informations
qui en tout cas il ya beaucoup de
pression pour que sa roue va partir du
21 juin
est ce que c'est le scénario c'est pas
le scénario qu'on nous a communiquée on
ne nous le groupe de travail qui
comprend des collègues d'anciens
politiciens des deux côtés de la
frontière
nous avons rencontré les hauts
fonctionnaires et du pays qui veut
attendait des signaux c'est possible ça
m'étonnerait vous savez le premier
ministre fort depuis une dizaine de
jours mais ma se plaît
fédérale sur la frontière il lui
souhaite d resservent au manitoba savoie
- moins bien alors on est loin du compte
pour pour tout le pays
et il y aura une élection fédérale à
l'automne je m'étonnerai que monsieur
trudeau prennent le risque d'une
réouverture de la frontière
d'autant plus que l'opinion publique au
canada est assez opposés à l'ouverture
des frontières monsieur fillion alors la
décision est beaucoup plus politique que
l'intérêt économique selon vous il ya
une portion de poids de la décision qui
est politique et aucun doute là-dessus
scientifique la santé je ne doute pas de
la bonne foi des gouvernements qui vont
placer les enjeux de santé aux premiers
rangs sage et aucun doute là dessus mais
vous savez à l'étape où nous sommes les
gens qui sont par exemple complètement
vaccinés deux doses à mon avis pourrait
très bien traversé la frontière en
faisant la démonstration la preuve
qu'ils sont vaccinés ou en acceptant de
faire des tests
on pourrait permette aux gens qui ont
des maisons d'un côté ou de l'autre de
la frontière d'aller voir leur maison de
visites ecce terra
on peut y aller graduellement mais il
n'ya aucun doute monsieur fillion qu'une
partie de la décision sera politique et
le tue les gouvernements font en
fonction de l'opinion et au canada le
pignon est assez fermement opposés à
l'ouverture à la réouverture en tout cas
total de la frontière politique interne
bien sûr mais quel est le poids des
pressions qui viennent des états unis en
ce moment pas plus tard qu'hier le
gouverneur du vermont
quand même pas un gros état mais c'est
un état frontalier a pressé les deux
pays de préparer ce plan de réouverture
des frontières il faut se préparer dit
il quelle est la force de ces pressions
qui viennent du monde économique et du
monde politique américain seller
pression pèse dépression en effet sous
les gouvernements mais essayons donc de
voir les échéanciers les gouvernements
pourraient déposer un plat nourrir près
ouvrir graduellement pendant l'été mais
une réouverture complète ou une
réouverture qui ressemble monsieur
fillion est ce que nous vivons
auparavant à mon avis c'est pas avant
fin septembre début mai pourrait très
bien avoir une ouverture de la duel du
système donc à partir de juillet-août sa
cellule ou peut-être graduellement mais
à nouveau
vous savez pour les gouvernements vont
être très sensibles à l'opinion publique
du côté canadien à tout le moins
puisqu'il y aura bientôt les élections
absolument
et combien ça coûte cette fermeture de
frontières en ce moment votre groupe de
réflexion du wilson center a quand même
chiffré le coût réel de la fermeture
c'est pour chiffrer ou deux personnes de
chiffrer à ce jour sur ce que nous
savons contrairement à l'expérience du
11-septembre milieu de ce live est le
circulation de marchandises s'est fait
assez librement
c'est au niveau des services et les
secteurs qui ont été de plus endommagé
c'est le secteur du tourisme évidemment
les loisirs d'hospitaliser l'hospitalité
et c'est surtout le côté canadien
monsieur fillion camper le brillant
c'est nous qui assume le fardeau
économique le plus important
il ya un prix humain aussi qui porte
anti fiable et ça c'est les gens qui
sont séparés de leurs familles de leurs
amis des communautés qui sont partagés
parce que la frontière est fermée ça ça
aussi c'est un coup dont il faut tenir
compte
lorsqu'on décide de réouvrir la france
est ce qu'un enjeu sur le passeport
vaccinale selon vous un blocage parce
que les américains ne mise pas sur le
passeport vaccinale est ce que le canada
pourrait se permettre de l'imposer la
culture politique américaine ce type de
contrôle à est très très docile à faire
accepter la population maintenant c'est
au côté canadien
je pense que l acceptabilité à des
conditions qui sont ou qui sont connus
passerait probablement ce que nous
anticipons nous c'est qu'à moyen terme
peut-être à plus long terme les deux
gouvernements exigeront que les
étrangers qui entrent en territoire
canadien où les étrangers qui entrent
aux états unis fassent la preuve de
vaccins moi moi je mon avis personnel
c'est que nous irons vers une obligation
de faire la preuve
le passeport l'accident comme instrument
et donc les américains qui viendraient
au canada devrait présenter une forme de
peuvent vacciner
oui à mon avis on dit vous bien il y
aura d'autres pandémies monsieur fillion
une des leçons de ce que nous vivons
actuellement c'est qu'il y en aura
d'autres et ça existe déjà pour ceux qui
on voyage en afrique sont très familiers
avec la carte santé jaune ou plusieurs
pays africains exigent qu'un étranger
fasse la démonstration qu'il a été
vaccinée pour la fièvre jaune alors
c'est pas nouveau
sauf que le niveau de contrôle
d'exigence pour l'avenir risque d'être
beaucoup plus élevé et et amnéville la
normalité
le nouveau normale sera probablement un
système où on devra faire la
démonstration nous avons ou été testés
ou vacciner avant d'entrer aux états
unis la même chose pour entrer au canada
bien merci monsieur charest d'avoir été
avec nous avec ces observations ce soir
très intéressant la prochaine merci
monsieur fillion roi pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit